one of my assistants that traveled with
me said after all these years this still
gets to you doesn't it i said man we
putting a man's body in there next to
his mother's grave yeah it gets to me
and i said let me tell you something
young man the minute it doesn't matter
to you anymore you need to leave the
movement it matters to me every one of
these deaths
[Music]
hello and welcome
if you want a long view of the battle
for racial justice and equality there
are few better witnesses than my guests
today
he went from pounding the streets of
america demanding change to having a
direct line to the white house
attracting strong praise and sharp
criticism for his style and tactics
along the way he is the civil rights
veteran the rev al sharpton who has been
on the front line of many of america's
most notorious police brutality cases
including caring for george floyd's
family as black lives matter protests
erupted around the world soul legend
james brown was a father figure to him
and now age 67 with a weekly tv and
daily radio show to his name he shows no
signs of slowing down
he now has his latest book out righteous
troublemakers in which he tells the
stories of those who have protest thrown
upon them reverend al thank you very
much for being with me and i thought i'd
start by asking is that how you describe
yourself a righteous troublemaker
well i do i think that uh it is uh you
know i got the
thought of it from john lewis uh who uh
was of course the congressman and
beloved in the civil rights movement
saying make good trouble and i i think
that uh i've tried to be a good
troublemaker all my life we'll come to
your record and how that's worked and
some of the tactics and how things have
changed but who are you trying to give
voice to in this book
i'm trying to give voice to people that
i feel made tremendous contributions but
never got the recognition
and the uh
visibility that i think
that they were merited for example
most people in the united states and in
uh around the western world would not
know the name of of claudette calvin
claudette calvin whose story i write
about in this book
was arrested for sitting in front of the
bus in segregated montgomery alabama
refusing to give up her seat
nine months before rosa parks but the
local montgomery black leadership didn't
want to rally around her because they
said she was too dark-skinned and she
was pregnant and was unmarried she
didn't have the moral picture they
wanted
it was her sitting in the front of the
bus that inspired rosa parks in fact
fred gray was the lawyer for both of
them and i wanted people to understand
that so that every day people would know
that you don't have to qualify to be a a
troublemaker or a freedom fighter
everybody has a contribution and these
people were just regular people that did
some things that were amazing and and
yet some of the people that you're also
talking about in the book have protests
thrust upon them it's not something that
they set out to do and and because they
find themselves a miscarriage of justice
and they find themselves in the eye of
the storm
how have you found their stories and at
times i know you've personally worked
with them and tried to get them ready
for something like that they're ordinary
people living just regular lives and all
of a sudden they're thrust out here in
the middle of uh what becomes a
milestone
uh
i talk about philonous floyd for example
filonus was just a regular guy in
houston texas
brother george floyd abused by police in
minneapolis
and
all of a sudden
they become a global
news story and a global movement
but
fallon is unlike a me or unlike others
didn't choose to be an activist he's
thrust out there and and that's one of
the reasons why uh national action
network has been involved in a lot of
these cases is you have to remember when
a police officer
is accused of a misdeed or a crime
they have the police unions that back
them up and provide them with lawyers
and resources and if they need a
therapist if they need uh people to help
them with interviews or to advise them
with media
families have none of that they wake up
one morning their brother their cousin
their son is dead
nobody's there to help him that's why
nash network provides all of that
because you need an institution to go up
against institutions and we can provide
all of that you're talking there about
the the organization that you you head
up to which helps people exactly i mean
you say in the book your job was to
build a firewall of support around the
floyd family to guide to protect them i
mean even though what had happened was
was horrendous and then became the
symbol of a newly ignited kind of global
movement
do you think that they could be prepared
for it i mean are they still sort of
coming out of that now i think that they
uh uh uh show tremendous growth
and uh uh and tremendous ability but
they had to have people that would
advise and guide them so the perception
is that uh uh old people like sharpton
and others run in when there is trouble
no we're called in the floyd family
called me i mean can you imagine you're
mourning
your brother in philosophy's case
fellowness floyd brother was killed how
he was killed you're watching on
television every night and how this is
killing you but there's 10
tv cameras outside your door that wants
an immediate response and you don't know
if you'll say something that might hurt
the
of the case that you want prosecuted
against the policeman so you need people
that will say be careful don't say this
don't uh say something out of rage that
they can use later all of that comes
with building a movement and all of that
happens to people that decide i'm going
to make trouble for a system that's
unfair but i'm going to do it in a
righteous way and that's why i talk
about it i got the idea
because when in the middle of george
floyd since we're talking about it they
had asked me to do the eulogy at uh both
his funeral in houston at his funeral in
minneapolis
and i remember in the middle of my
given the delivering the eulogy uh just
for whatever reason it hit me
uh because i've always always been an
extemporaneous speaker because i started
preaching i was a kid so i don't use a
manuscript and it hit me and i said we
need to march on washington we need to
bring
the issue of police reform and police
misconduct to washington we had over 200
000 people and i'm on my way to the uh
to the steps where dr king had spoke
in 1963 to make the speech after the
families of of uh george
floyd with me family of ahmed aubry with
me family of jacob blake family of
brianna taylor about 15 victims family
we're all walking toward the stage and
in these throngs of people i see an old
man that was jumping up and down with an
object in his hand trying to get my
attention and i said to the security
around me i said
what is that old man trying to tell me
and they says well remember we need to
keep you moving i said no but this old
man looks like he's in his 80s he's
trying to say something
go get him and they went and got him
brought him to me
and he showed me what he had in his hand
was a button
and he said march on washington freedom
now he said i was here in 63 with martin
luther king and i want to be here today
with you and this is the button i won
63.
and that kind of haunted me i never
forgot that man because he just went
back in the crowd and i said you know
there are people that have paid a price
did went to the marches went to the
rallies some went to jail some were
killed
that knew they were never going to be in
the newspaper
the next day they were not going to be
on the news that night they were just
righteous troublemakers they were there
for the cause suppose if people like me
call them archer nobody came
these people came 200 000 people in the
middle of a pandemic at their own
expense at their own risk
why don't we that have the limelight put
a limelight on some of them and that's
where the book concept came from on that
point though i i was wondering when you
get that call you yourself because you
have been doing this for so long
faith is obviously a huge part of your
life
how do you
deal with that because you still seeing
people losing their lives you're still
seeing these police brutality cases
i think if i didn't have a deep
spiritual life and faith
it would overtake me because
it hurts
to stand over these
funerals and look at these bodies over
and over again i've done since george
floyd maybe 10 funerals of victims since
then there's no way that would not wear
on you unless you had a faith to believe
that this is the work that you were born
to do i'm watching families i'm trying
to comfort them and at the same time
asking myself god how long will this
last how many times do we have to go
through this before the laws are changed
so if i were to tell you it didn't get
to me uh i i would be lying i i tell you
and i wrote about this in the book
after george floyd's funeral
the last one in houston and we had the
long motorcade uh to bury him next to
his mother and i remember i did the
prayer i did the commitment of the body
and then i uh hugged the family and i
left to head to the airport to head back
to new york
and i had my head down and the little
teary eyed and one of my assistants that
traveled with me said after all these
years this still gets to you doesn't it
i said man we putting a man's body in
there next to his mother's grave yeah it
gets to me and i said let me tell you
something young man the minute it
doesn't matter to you anymore you need
to leave the movement it matters to me
every one of these deaths how much do
you feel faith is is
baked into the politics of america
though because it is it's very distinct
when you're looking in
that it's so
linked and you can see people on
different political sides
defending their views or using sometimes
christianity in particular to say this
is god's will do you think that faith is
being weaponized in american politics in
a way that that is just unhealthy
i think that it has definitely been
weaponized in a way that's unhealthy
because i think that we've used faith as
a
way of
making people
other than us or that other than believe
wicked and therefore if you can make
them wicked and make them some kind of
of anti what god would want that it
justifies treating them unequally and
treating them unfairly which is why i
think people of faith have to say i'm
motivated by my faith but i want to
protect people's rights that may not
even have a faith i remember when i came
out for lgbtq rights many many years ago
and i even supported uh gay marriage
some of the clergymen that i preach for
are in their churches as a guest
minister said to me reverend al i don't
know if we could have you to church this
year because a lot of our parishioners
are not with you on that same-sex
marriage and i said well okay then i'm
not coming
i think when there is just a blurring of
the lines as there still seems to be in
america at times with faith and with
politics i mean
it can be that people do not see it as
the law they see it as imposing people's
views on them and i i wonder what you
think would come first an atheist
president of america or a female
president well uh uh i i don't i
probably would say a female president
uh but i don't rule it out i mean when i
got started as a as a youngster in the
movement i never thought i'd see a black
president so it's it it would not
shock me that either would come but my
guess would be a female president we
already now have a female vice president
indeed well it's it's still not happened
but i suppose whatever political side
you're on the candidate has to believe
in god and has to prove it in some way
which is striking regardless of how you
come at it just talking about the phrase
righteous troublemaker
and i was thinking about what happened
just over a year ago on the capitol
you know those
rioters
would probably describe themselves in a
similar way as righteous troublemakers
they believe in what they are doing they
believe in what they're marching for and
i suppose what would you say being
someone who's protested your whole life
and being so divided from those with a
view who have of what they're doing
being just as worthy as what you're
doing
i would say to them that what will make
the difference of whether what you're
doing is righteous or unrighteous is the
end goal
what are you trying to do they were
there that day january 6
to stop the certification of an election
that the american people had chosen a
president if you're going to have a
righteous cause the end the goal must be
righteous and your behavior to achieve
the goal must be righteous neither was
the case in the january 6 insurrection
because some say what happened on the
capitol was the beginning of something
not the end of something and 75 million
people voted for trump in the last
election and i i just wondered from your
side of things as it were
how do you see this playing out if the
sides just can't talk to each other
because you've you've built movements
i think that uh
i agree with those that say january 6
was the beginning
of something
they are not going anywhere they have
gone into states now changing voting
laws
or they have built an infrastructure
around this big lie that trump really
won
and that they want to in some way
control how votes are counted and how
votes are done
i think we're in for a long season
of confronting
voting rights and different sides
opposing different sides on these
questions and i don't know that we're
going to be able to get to this dialogue
of healing uh for a minute now i think
this is going to play itself out i think
the election
of joe biden and the four years of
donald trump has divided the united
states more than i've seen it in my
lifetime
looking at
movements then and looking at how things
can hopefully get better or improve of
course as i say you've been protesting
you've been on the streets for a long
long time and you've seen things that
you couldn't have imagined like a black
president like you just said but i was
just thinking about tactics and changing
approach of course many hailed the black
lives movement protests because they
didn't erupt in violence they didn't
erupt in riots although there have also
been divisions within that some factions
calling for the defunding of the police
just a word on that
where are you on that and where do you
think the movement is on that because
there is division i think as any
movement there's always going to be
disagreements within the movement uh you
know i grew up in the north uh the year
martin luther king was killed i was 13.
i was already youth director of of his
chapter in new york there were people
that disagreed with dr king they're
saying that they believed in
self-defense not non-violence they
believed in uh then you had those on the
other side that had condemned dr king uh
for coming out against the war in
vietnam saying that we should be for
whatever president johnson wanted
because he was a good civil rights
president so these disagreements exist i
think that we need to reform the police
but we need to keep a measure of
policing in our communities because we
have high crimes you've got as much a
problem with gun violence as you have a
problem of dealing with police that are
over the line and do things that are
wrong
and that in in many cases are criminal
uh so i think that it is restructuring
how you put the funds and how you fund
policing but you must have policing
three weeks after i did the eulogy for
george floyd's funeral i did the eulogy
of a one-year-old child
that was killed in a crossfire of gangs
fighting in brooklyn so we need both we
need good policing
funded properly that deal with things
like mental health and gun control and
there's also of course this push and
hope that the police themselves will
report bad cops will also come forward
and and have that culture change within
there as well as the training and the
policing that they've got to do that you
talk about and just thinking about
people who may be thinking of themselves
in the way that you've described a
righteous troublemaker talking about
making good trouble as you said right at
the beginning of our conversation and if
you think back to your your younger self
and how you've changed as a protester
and your tactics
what is your biggest regret and what's
the lesson you've learned what i've
learned is that you should not
shoot from the hill we often say
tit-for-tat report or somebody say
something i'm almost at at the beginning
of their last word answering them
be more thoughtful to make sure whatever
you say
and whatever you do and whatever tactics
you use is toward achieving the end goal
that you profess because people are
depending on you
and they expect you to be thoughtful not
just theatrical one of the controversies
that is still brought up by your critics
is your response to the 1991 crown
heights riots in new york
to remind our viewers these took place
after a seven-year-old black boy was
killed in a motorcade by a motorcade
transporting a rabbi violence broke out
after that death and a jewish student
was killed your critics say you never
called on the rioters to stop their
anti-semitic inspired violence is that
fair
that's totally erroneous because as the
state of new york did a study i was not
even in crown heights when the rabbi a
young rabbi student was killed i was
called by the family of the
seven-year-old kid the next day
but many in the fringe
right wing try and distort that i was
somehow should have called for them not
to do what they did that night when i
was living in new jersey but these are
the kinds of things that you have to
deal with and you keep going that is not
only unfair it's untrue that's why
that's why i wanted to ask you about it
i mean you did mark the 20th anniversary
of the incident you wrote an opinion
piece in the new york daily news and you
said our language and tone sometimes
exacerbated tensions and played to the
extremists and actually there was a
response from from the young man's
brother
um who responded saying he felt your
recollections were sanitized and and
distorted so there's obviously still a
lot of hurt and pain that but again
we're talking uh 30 what how many years
ago all you have to do is go to the
state report who by the way criticized
david dinkins the media and others but
said
sharpton was not there now i said that
when i came in
that maybe i could have as i did the
eulogy for the seven-year-old kid's
funeral said more things that would have
been uh that i they would say
differently but to say that i incited or
excused violence it's just not true and
even in his brother's statement saying
sanitize whatever as a man of opinion he
could not say that i incited violence i
i suppose it's just when you are looking
back at tactics and how protests happen
and the leadership i suppose that you've
had it's about also learning from that
which is what i wanted to ask you about
because you'll be well aware of these
criticisms over the years
right i think that what i've learned and
what i share
is keep your eye on the prize what is it
that you're going for don't react to the
crowd don't play to uh mrs martin luther
king coretta scott kings tell me don't
play to the cheap seats to get the
roaring of the crowd she said think
about what you're trying to achieve and
speak to that and that's what i've had
to learn i just wanted to ask about the
next generation of leaders that you have
in your site particularly around racial
equality are there some that you are
particularly keeping an eye on i have
many in my uh national action network
and some beyond that i'm looking at i
won't call names but there are some that
are very impressive and i tell them that
they've got to learn in their generation
what works and they're going to be
tested and you're going to be criticized
and being a troublemaker you're going to
have trouble because
the fact that you're questioning
speaking truth to power power is going
to answer you so make sure
you are absolutely committed and want to
be there to do that but keep your eye on
the prize don't make my mistakes
you can study people like me and others
but study also where we fell short and
correct them as we go and also health i
imagine you have an amazing regime
you could keep going for longer i
suppose you if you don't mind me
mentioning you've lost an enormous
amount of weight and you post about
drinking your kale juice every day and
you look great i've lost 176 pounds over
the last four years i am a vegetarian
eat one meal a day work out uh 35
minutes every morning and i'm in better
shape now at 67 than i was at 37. well
long long may it continue and do you
work out listening to james brown of
course a lot of times i do he was like
my dad first time i went to london james
brown brought me he played at the
hammersmith odium
and uh i worked with james brown he
brought me to london and i listened a
lot of his music is up tempo so it helps
me when i'm on the elliptical or lifting
weights that's what you're doing it too
uh reverend al sharpton thank you very
much indeed for your your time your
recollections and and some of your
lessons thank you god bless thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again mask up stay safe and goodbye
[Music]
you